vos priorités pour la jeunesse de
Bourgogne Franche-Comté je souhaite la
sécurité pour nos jeunes en Bourgogne
Franche-Comté toutes les mesures que je
viens d'entendre sont intéressantes
malheureusement toutes les mesures que
je viens d'entendre seront totalement
inefficaces si les Bourguignons et les
francs-contois et notamment les plus
jeunes ne sont pas en sécurité dans
notre région il y a une crise
aujourd'hui qui est celle de l'EN
sauvagement de l'ultra violence qui mine
notamment notre jeunesse et c'est vrai
qu'on peut parler développement
économique on peut parler de formation
on peut parler d'insertion on peut
parler de développement professionnel si
les gens ne sont pas en sécurité si les
Bourguignons et les Franc-Comtois ne
sont pas en sécurité cela ne marchera
pas et notre région continuera
dégringoler sur la perte d'attractivité
donc moi je souhaite et je l'assume
totalement que la sécurité devienne une
compétence régionale et notamment pour
notre jeunesse parce que pendant la
campagne j'ai rencontré des centaines de
jeunes des filles des garçons des
étudiants des jeunes en apprentissage et
la plupart d'entre eux m'ont fait part
n'ont pas de leurs sentiments comme le
dit le président de la République mais
des réalités de l'insécurité dans les
gares dans les transports dans l'espace
public aujourd'hui c'est insupportable
et notamment pour les femmes et
notamment pour les plus fragiles donc
moi je souhaite un programme pour lutter
contre l'insécurité avec les leviers de
la région ça passera notamment par un
fond d'aide un fond d'aide pour les
victimes de l'insécurité qui
malheureusement sont beaucoup trop
nombreuses et notamment les femmes
victimes de violence conjugales 5
millions d'euros par an pour les
victimes de l'insécurité ensuite un
recrutement recrutement d'agents armés
pour sécuriser l'égard et les transports
et pour renforcer les effectifs de
police de gendarmerie de police
municipale ensuite financer les polices
municipales donc dans les petites
communes qui n'ont pas le budget parce
que c'est indispensable et ensuite une
mesure extrêmement claire qui m'est cher
ce que j'appelle la sécu conditionnalité
c'est qu'aujourd'hui la candidate
sortante a déversé beaucoup d'argent
dans les quartiers dix prioritaires qui
sont les quartiers les plus dangereux
moi je souhaite responsab tous les
acteurs associatifs et il locaux pour
faire en sorte qu'ils des critères en
matière de renforcement de la sécurité
en matière de renforcement des valeurs
républicaines et de la laïcité je pense
qu'aujourd'hui la sécurité doit devenir
une priorité régionale merci